j'ai un fashion truc qui s'appelle mode
and truck qui est une boutique
itinérante aménagé dans un petit fond
bon et si on est un petit peu tout lit
donc à un jour une commune différente
gens qui sont intéressés ou qui voit le
camion passait ils peuvent consulter le
calendrier sur mon site web donc
www.entrust.com
le fait de me démarquer d'aller dans
l'est par exemple des quartiers la fin
ça permet également aux dames qui
travaillent jusqu'à 17h 18h30 de samy à
d'autres endroits que dans les
franchises et de pouvoir différencier de
par leur nous qu'il se sentir peut-être
mieux au quotidien des produits que je
vends donc c'est pour la plupart des
mains françaises après j'ai quelques
créateurs locaux dans le textile et j'ai
plutôt des créateurs locaux dans la
partie d'où j'ai connu une période de
chômage
ça ça m'a vraiment permis de me
consacrer entièrement à mon projet parce
que ça demande quand même beaucoup de
temps j'avais envie de me lancer dans la
création d'entreprise mais sur un
concept un peu différent décalé qui me
donne une certaine liberté
moi j'ai pris un an avant de pouvoir
vraiment le lancer
parce que dans la création d'entreprise
il faut avoir une sphère familiale assez
stable et soutenue par ses amis sa
famille et moi ça a été le cas à pas mal
de monde qui m'ont donné un petit peu là
à la force d'en arriver jusque là
comme j'ai suivi le projet de a à z
je sais qu'elle est passé par des
moments de doute où elle s'est dit est
ce que je le fais ou est-ce que j'arrête
tout est d'être derrière elle pour lui
dire qu'il faut continuer parce que
c'est ce qu'elle aime parce que elle va
pouvoir vivre de sa passion
c'est vrai que ça a été une bonne chose
de suivre ce projet et oui appartement
je suis fier de voir que le projet
existait en puisque le projet a fêté ses
un an il n'y a pas très longtemps et que
ça va durer dans le temps
mon projet a débuté à la participation
de plusieurs personnes ce que j'ai fait
un financement participative les
personnes pouvaient donner 5 10 20 euros
pour constituer une cagnotte il ya pu
augmenter mon apport bancaire pour
solliciter à un prix je me suis fait
aider par donc réunion entreprendre et
la boutique de gestion mais également
donc la d2r on a beaucoup de curieux qui
viennent pour regarder que ce luth
féminin ou masculin pour le coup est
aujourd'hui de toute façon même les
curieux à venir voir comment c'est fait
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est important
de faire un métier qu'on aime est vrai
que moi jamais avoir une certaine
liberté dans ce que je fais j'aime
rencontrer les gens et surtout j'aime
beaucoup la mode donc c'est un moyen
pour moi de m'exprimer on peut dire que
c'est un rêve qui s'est concrétisée